welcome back to the road to 2000s my
name is Caleb Denby as always I'm your
driver on this road hopefully we'll all
well arrive at 2000 safely together so
if you saw the class last week what I
wanted to talk about was tactical motifs
so I feel like that's a lot of what
weaker players and beginner players need
to work on but a lot of players run into
this problem where okay they learn these
patterns they do tactics but they're
actually unable to put it into effect in
their games so what I wanted to talk
about today it's a pretty broad topic
it's basically recognizing tactics in
your games recognizing where they show
up when they show up and why they show
up so basically the plan for today is
I'm just going to go through five
different games of all different levels
and we'll see how tactics show up and
how they differ from each other in the
different levels of games so this first
game we go over is actually from the
Chess Club staff tournament it was very
exciting and it was between Jesse
Richardson who is kind of a casual chess
player he just likes playing the game he
never really spent much time studying it
and trying to get very good and Kyle
Weber who's one of our scholastic
coordinators he helps run all their
scholastic programs and he's about 1500
USCF so he spent some time and he's
gotten a bit better at chess so I wanted
to go over how tactics show up in a game
between a slightly more beginner player
like Jesse and a player who's been
playing for a while now like Kyle and
we'll see how the tactics work out how
Kyle managed to gain an advantage and
eventually went so just jumping right
off he went d4 Jesse didn't which is
totally fine an opening move guarding
the center Knight f6 Knight f3 II 693 so
already this move is a bit weird
from Jesse it doesn't really follow the
normal plans for the structure but
that's fine he's by no means worse at
this point Kyle went for c5 attacking
this the center pawn as
you know Jesse didn't get the C C pawn
in the game to help defend this pawn or
help defend this d5 square Jesse just
played III which is fine just defends
the pawn C takes d4 he takes d4 a6
Bishop d3 developing moves d6 from Kyle
this move is also a little bit weird
probably you should have just controlled
the center in the normal fashion but he
wanted to keep an eye on this this dark
e5 square so white goes that goes on
castles Bishop e7 Bishop e3 and so White
has pretty much got most of his pieces
developed now let me ask the live
audience here is this a position where
tactics are gonna start flowing already
or there are you're already going to be
like a lot of tactics here why not yeah
so when you say opportunities for
tactics what are you looking for that
makes you think okay here I've got to
have a tactic here I've got to have
something that I should look out for
right so yeah so nothing is being
attacked and you know White's not really
you know working together coordinating
on a single point at all and so this is
not really a position where tactics are
going to occur so a couple of things
that we need to look out for in tactics
and we'll touch more on this when they
actually show up is loose pieces so what
do I mean when I say loose pieces do you
know what that means yeah so undefended
pieces pieces that are further advanced
than this should be pieces that are you
know maybe defended once but you know
obviously could could use some more
defending so when pieces are loose
that's when tactics kind of show up and
then there's one other huge criteria I
wanted to touch on as well so we have
loose pieces and then also if your
pieces are just much more active than
the near opponent's piece activity as
well as looser undefended pieces that's
what kind of makes tactics show up and
so it's learning to recognize when you
have active pieces when your opponent
does not and when your opponent has
loose pieces that's what you want to
learn to recognize
to find tactics in your own games so
let's see how this continued black
castles Bishop g5 Knight B d7 d5 so
already this should raise some alarm
bells
why does d5 you know rate race and raise
some alarms in your head right away oh
yeah it's it's moving to a square where
it's attacked right yeah it's it's
attacked twice and only only defended
once so this is a moment when you're
playing with the white pieces maybe
you're a more beginner player and you're
trying to find your move right and you
think oh maybe this d5 move looks good
it's attacking my opponent right and so
this is when you have to start being
very careful and start looking very
carefully at the position this is like
the first step to recognizing when
tactics are going to happen especially
to you you need to see when you're
moving into enemy territory when your
pieces are a bit more loose or when like
they're on an attack Square even so here
black has you know a tactic already he
can take this pawn he can take it in two
different ways which way do you think he
should capture
yeah why take it what the night well
what would happen if if white just
captured here would you have to double
the pawns anyways yeah so this is making
use of whites only other loose piece a
under defended piece you know he's moved
to pieces into a kind of enemy territory
here his bishop and his pawn and both of
them together make a tactic that works
black can capture this pawn on d5 and
maybe what White was thinking was you
know if he just takes here with the pawn
that's not so bad for me right this pawn
is gonna be very weak and maybe I can
win it back but unfortunately black does
have this tactic and Knight takes d5 and
the reason that this works is because
White had to lose pieces and that allows
black to do this tactic so if white were
to try to recapture here trying to
double these pawns black would actually
just capture on g5 and that would be a
completely fine for him and if he were
to take on e7 again what the idea of
taking here black can actually just
retreat his knight and recapture and
black would just be up a healthy pawn so
this is kind of how tactics start
showing up at the most basic level you
know white he's kind of a casual player
he just wants to move his pawns forward
and he's only made two loose pieces but
together already a tactic is working
Kyle actually chose to play Knight c5
which is a bit worse than just cleanly
winning the pawn but uh if by no means
is black any worse here Bishop e2 white
didn't want to lose this Bishop and it
does add another defender to this pawn
unfortunately this this tactic still
does work for black you can still just
capture here whoops whoops
we lost internet connection
okay we're back Bishop takes you seven
and nine takes e7 and now this pawn is a
bit weaker than it was before but black
would still just be up upon instead uh
you know Kyle still didn't notice this
so even at the 1500 level it's all about
noticing hey this piece is loose this
piece is loose can I make something work
because I'm sure Kyle was capable of
calculating this he just didn't really
look for it so 94 instead trading the
bishops who threatening to trade the
bishops and again you know your opponent
makes a threatening looking move you
should notice this piece is a bit loose
it's a bit overextended and under
defended and so white didn't notice
though and now of course like just wins
the bishop and I'll just quickly go
through and see how a black eventually
did win we see that you know white made
a threat actually black defended well
though I don't wanna spend too much time
on this and then we have another loose
piece situation right this Queen is out
kind of on its own with no other pieces
and it runs into this discovered attack
and this Bishop is also loose so notice
how whenever there's a tactic it always
seems like white's pieces are misplaced
or kind of overextended and loose and
that's really when you need to you know
turn on the brain think really hard okay
is there any way i can take advantage of
my opponent's piece placement so after
the Queen the game ended very shortly
with checkmate on f2 so Kyle won that
one but uh no worries later in the staff
tournament he had to play me alright and
now I wanted to feature our very own
Perry Coulson who you may know from our
famous twitch livestreams that are going
on now he's also in the room with us and
this is a game you know Perry might be a
little bit embarrassed about but there's
there's really no reason to because he
handed up winning in the ends so let's
see you know how he kind of went awry to
start off with and then how his opponent
went further awry so we have a
Budapest's defense actually been punched
and a work
yeah first time Perry had seen it first
time so he correctly surmised that
blacks pawn is undefended and he
captures it like a champion Knight and
g4 so black is just attempting to regain
this fun uh yeah so Bishop f4 is the
main move Knight f3 is by no means a bad
move
just knight c6 Knight c3 here probably
white should have defended this pawn
because now it's it's open to capture
it's also open to Bishop b4 maybe maybe
it could happen instead we see Bishop
yeah Bishop before and this gives white
a chance to actually to defend his pawn
but now you know this is actually just
an opening line in the Budapest's I
prefer to put this knight on b2 where it
can't be captured on c3 like this but by
no means is any player done anything
wrong here Queenie 7 and now white made
a pretty substantial mistake so he
played Bishop to g5 yes why is this move
wrong first of all yeah so there are a
couple things wrong with it is this
Bishop was serving a very useful purpose
on f4 and defending this pawn and you've
also moved it twice now you've kind of
done a stutter step between f4 and g5
and you don't really want to be moving
the same piece over and over again in
the opening like this it's definitely
going to lead to two problems and so
yeah and the third thing I wanted to
mention is this Bishop is a bit loose on
g5 right on f4 it's it's undefended but
it's kind of closer to home and maybe
after e3 this Bishop will be defended
because III I think would be the the
right move here this Bishop will be
defended it's still defending the pawn
and you're also getting this Bishop
developed at the same time so he's made
a loose piece so it's not a problem yet
but it might be a problem later in the
game right this is what we always want
to be thinking about what
at the loose pieces to recognize if we
have a tactic so the Queen the c5 is
played which actually is threatening
checkmate
well not quite checkmate but you know
what I mean so e3 is correct just
defending against the threat now Knight
takes e5 and now already we can kind of
see an x-ray attack one of the tactical
motifs I went over last week is kind of
occurring on this bishop and also we're
looking out for maybe an intermezzo and
a discovered attack eventually so all of
these motifs have suddenly appeared and
they didn't come out of nowhere they
came because first of all black has more
active pieces all those pieces are
developed I mean while white is still
you know finishing development if you
want to just go by numbers you can count
this Queen as I know I developed piece
that white doesn't really have yet so
black is more developed he's more active
and white has a loose piece this is what
leads to tactics so this is what you
really want to look out for be very
aware when you move your pieces forward
and to under the undefended spaces and
especially you know when they're this
close to opponent territory that's a
very common mistake that I see and
that's why all these tactics show up in
all your games so here what do you think
white should have done to try to save as
much material as he could
yeah I think I think moving the bishop
back or perhaps capturing the knight
first and then moving the bishop back is
is the best that I can really do there
is also this idea of playing something
like Queen to d5 I think which does
defend this pawn and maybe if you're
lucky you can you can get a piece trade
in and I think this this would still be
okay for black but I okay for white but
maybe maybe I would still prefer black
in that position instead we got Bishop
to e2 and then I'm sure you can all find
this tactic any ideas
yeah parry knows it how to win the
bishop well yeah there's to move orders
with the same idea but yeah of course
the main idea is this Knight takes f3
check black in the game inserted Bishop
takes c3 which doesn't really change
anything and now we see Knight takes f3
but the attack on the bishop and the
attack on the King and at the end of the
day black is simply up a piece and parry
almost threw in the towel but uh but
yeah obviously at these at these levels
anything can really happen in in any
game so you definitely don't want to
just give up and something else that I
see a lot of players do is they keep on
playing but they kind of stop thinking
about their moves they kind of just go
through the motions and that's the same
as resigning pretty much you have to
really stay in the game and keep
thinking about ways to mix it up and
keep things complicated instead we see
Castle instead of resigns castles
castles Queen c2 Knight East 7 already
this move is a little bit strange
maybe black was worried about doubling
the pawns but that's not really a threat
he should really just be getting his
pieces out and said we see ninety-seven
rook to be one putting pressure on this
pawn so black responds with c6 we're up
to d1 already white is activating his
pieces so this is what's allowing him to
find some tactics in the future is
getting these active pieces Knight to f5
again may
we should be looking for ways to develop
this bishop although night at 5:00 I
don't think is a bad move Bishop e4 and
now we finally do see d6
defending the knight and you know
preparing to develop the bishop rook
back to f1 not my favorite move but it
does it doesn't have an idea behind it
you see York to e8 now actually f4 and
this was White's idea which I'm having a
hard time endorsing this because yeah
because it doesn't make quite a bit of
weaknesses and it leaves a lot of pieces
loose but you know it is nice and the
fact that you're you found a way to get
your rook into an active position so the
you know the heart behind the move was
was fine taken what not yeah 93 so yeah
you might think you have a tactic here
with Knight takes III cuz again there's
a loose piece so you all definitely want
to be looking for it for the tactic it
does actually lose a piece back though
at the end of the day black would lose a
knight whereas white lost just one pawn
I think but yeah that's good you want to
be recognizing hey my opponent just made
a weird-looking move it left a piece
undefended I should be checking for
tactics instead we saw Queen h5 White
defenses pondan develops his rook and
via a different route than he originally
chose and now black thinks he has a
tactic here black black sees hey wait a
second I have this Queen in this rook in
this night and this Bishop can kind of
come into the game too it feels like I
should have something here because first
of all this piece I think qualifies as
loose it's not undefended but is
attacked once and defended once so that
makes it kind of loose and these pieces
are all a little disc ordinated so black
was correct in thinking hey maybe I have
something here how do I make something
work so what tactical motifs and what
ideas do you see for black possibly
without checking the actual game
notation
yes so that's something to point out we
know the tactical motif of a skewer or a
pen right and we know that maybe if we
somehow had a bishop on this diagonal we
could be winning
you know the rook by attacking the Queen
making the Queen move and then taking
the rook so that's one idea that you can
see you can recognize this pattern and
you're like okay I know that it looks
like these are lined up for your skewer
is there any way I can make a skewer
happen and then you can just search for
a way to make that happen
well first of all you have to get rid of
this bishop so that might lead you to
thinking about rook takes e4 but then
you might notice hey well I can't really
bring my Bishop to f5 put this knight in
the way and that's actually how black
arrived at his games at the sequency
played in the game
I obviously I'm not a mind reader but
that's the kind of thought process you
can kind of think about to lead you to
find tactics like this yeah so any ideas
how can he vacate the f5 square and set
up for this skewer yes so he plays
Knight H for winning a tempo on the rook
right so now the rook has to move and
now he actually plays this sacrifice
your rook takes e4 Queen takes e4 with
the idea of Bishop f5 so this was all
very well done by black but he missed
something what did he miss yeah it's a
very simple move by white which is easy
to understand why it you know black
didn't give it too much thought yeah
what do you think white did which
prevents black from taking his rook on
b1
yeah yes so it's just it's the only move
that doesn't lose the Queen Queen to d4
and then uh black took the rook but what
does white have now yeah it's it's
simply checkmate and this is actually
how the game ended Perry just Perry won
by checkmate through some a little bit
of cunning a little bit of hustling I
think you know I don't know at the board
would you like oh man Queen diva I can't
look don't do it yeah so you're happy
too happy to say that blacks a bit
better right so yeah we can turn on the
engine right yeah perhaps but I mean
let's not bother with that cuz it takes
forever to load but but yeah I mean
black wood maybe you know trying to
defend this and maybe work g5 here Queen
e2 and something like takes wouldn't
work so our chief oh maybe just takes
here yeah we can go back to the
beginning of the tactic so yeah
basically all in all I do want to touch
on this move here you do have to pay
attention to what your opponent's doing
obviously and it's not too late for
black to save this game with something
like Knight to g6 or Ponzi secretary
Bishop to g6 but yeah obviously the game
ended like this much - Jason's yeah
shukran but okay the beginning of the
tactic what did you want to look at
the plane d5 first perhaps dragon
initiative and then go inside h4 so the
move d5 here okay yeah so it looks like
the problem is gonna be I can just take
this and then a play Bishop d3 maybe
yeah but I mean this is another tactic
where you can win this pawn maybe maybe
winning this pawn is all you need
although actually I'm not sure you can
oh yeah this might be falling for more
tricks right so yeah black definitely
has to be careful right cuz you know
black doesn't meet some of the criteria
for hoping there's attacked Amin's but
in his position you know this piece is
loose this piece is loose but he has
problems of his own right we see that he
does have this kind of weak back rank if
something were to go wrong this Bishop
isn't yet developed he's looking for
ways to develop it with tempo and you
know these pieces are all kind of loose
right so both sides might have tactics
here which is why you have to be
extremely extremely cautious in
positions like this but yeah so the
point again I want to hammer home
obviously there's a lot of things that
happen in this game a lot of mistakes
were made but it's all about recognizing
hey my opponent's pieces are pretty
active I have some problems in my
position I need to be careful here or
you know thinking hey my opponent has
some loose pieces he has a weak back
rink he has you know I have threats on
g7 maybe what can I do to try to you
know cobble something together it's all
about recognizing when you have tactics
so yeah this first game was a game
between a beginner and a 1500 this was a
game between Perry who's past the gunner
level now I'd say he's about eleven
twelve hundred and so now we're gonna go
up up significantly from there and this
is a game that I recently had it was a
rapid game against Neil Deshpande who is
a member of the club and he is around
1750 I think 1700 maybe 1800 and so
let's see what you know tactics look
like at this level this next level up
here so we see d4 Knight of 6 c4 g6
see 3d5 so if a Greenfeld defense and
I'm just gonna go through it rather
quickly we exchanged and the point of
this opening is black puts a lot of
pressure on this d4 pawn and white tries
to maintain kind of a strong center as I
think of a simple way to put it
so we have castles this should be 296
castles Bishop g4 and I played rugby one
after the game we I kind of talked with
my opponent and he thought maybe you
should have captured here first before
Bishop g4 maybe you should have done a
few things differently but uh the way he
played it I don't think was too bad
mission g4 rook e1 yet
so this is actually slightly a mistake
because it allows black to simplify into
a fairly simple endgame with something
like this
and I wouldn't have much advantage here
like wouldn't have much advantage here
it kind of just be equal but my opponent
decided not to go for that and instead
defended his beep on with b6 yeah I
would say so I think black really had to
just go for this this equal ending which
you can kind of qualify this yeah just
taken here gotten rid of all these pawns
and achieved an equal position you can
kind of count this as a tactic because
this piece you could say is loose you
know it's defended one to three times
but it's attacked
well it's defended four times and
attacked four times but you can remove a
defender and then win that pawn an
exchange white gets this loose piece on
d7 but it would have just you know
equaled out in the ends which you just
see all that by calculating through and
making sure you you've seen everything
it's yeah so the question was you know
if you're trying to count defenders of
upon and attackers of a pawn or a piece
do you count the piece on the square is
anything and the answer is you really
don't and when you're accounting
attackers and defenders there doesn't
even have to be a piece there it could
just be you know of a square can I move
to this square you
threatening something else so yeah this
this pawn is basically nothing so once
this pawn would capture it no longer is
an attacker and so I would have four
defenders or four attackers to three
defenders is the way you would count
that now which is why he has to capture
here before you can capture here but
okay so that none of that happens black
instead decided just defend his pawn and
now I played the correct move which is
to push through which is removing this
this tactic where you can remove my
defender and capture my pawn this Knight
is loose in attacks so he has to move it
he goes to a5 which is kind of the edge
of the board but you know it's a common
idea on the grid Felder's trying to
control this square I just continued
development with Queen c2 yeah I think
95 was correct here the only other
option is really to take on f3 like this
when maybe I take with the Bishop maybe
I take with the pawn I'm actually not
sure let's say pawn takes and then he
can come to this a 5 square but the
thing is he kind of gets kicked away
right away and maybe he was a bit afraid
of seeing this this come down the board
yeah so he would say a5 instead I guess
you can consider 98 an option with the
idea of coming back this way but see I'm
not so sure about it
so Knight a5 is fine I play Queen c2
defending this pawn and connecting the
rooks and again probably tactics aren't
going to show up just yet cuz you know
we've both done a pretty good job we've
both developed and you can count this
Bishop as being loose but there's no way
for me to really take advantage of it
cuz you know I don't have any good
discoveries you know nothing that I
can't really capture you know I can just
take here after any of those moves and
this night you might think it's loose
but it is defended by this pawn and
there's not much I can do about that for
the moment so there's not really any
tactics flowing here just yet we see
Queen to d6 c4 so I'm you know adding an
extra defender to this pawn and maybe
I'm thinking about ways I can take
advantage of this Knight
maybe I'll play something like Bishop to
d2 and black will start feeling a little
uncomfortable because this Knight is way
out here kind of
on its own we see Rick - Rick a to d8 I
play a four so now I'm actually kind of
preparing to play Bishop to d2 so I can
push through with a five and I wouldn't
call these tactics yet this is more of a
positional plan as pushing this pawn
through and trying to take on b6 but the
tactics will will come later I promise
so we see Bishop to c8 and this was kind
of a strange idea I think what he wanted
to go for is something like Bishop to a6
and putting pressure on this pawn but it
is all a bit kind of too much it's kind
of miss placing his pieces so I played
Bishop d2 as I plans plays Knight to b7
because he didn't want to let me take
care and open this file for my rook fair
enough so he plays Knight to d7 instead
I just develop my rook you know I'm not
trying to do anything fancy I'm just
getting my pieces active because once
the pieces are active that's when
tactics flow so now black plays up five
so I consider this to be a pretty huge
mistake why do you think that is without
looking at concrete lines you can
already tell that this move is not going
to be good yes so not only did he open
up his King he opened up the position in
general right he opened up the center
and when you're opening things up you
want to be sure you're the person with
the more active pieces otherwise the
tactics kind of flow against you you
know your opponent has more options if
he has more active pieces there are more
things you can do more things you can
attack and usually something ends up
falling so we just look at the pieces
here this bishops only on the second
rank but it controls a lot of key
squares this Bishop is also only on the
second rank I'd say this is my least
active piece but it can easily be
activated on this new open diagonal this
rook is well placed for the opening of
this file and this Knight is well placed
to jump into some key squares right so
all my pieces are kind of ready ready
for this opening of the game whereas I
mean he has a knight on b7
right there's Knight can almost not
legally move the only square can go to
is back to a5 which it doesn't want to
do this Bishop is stuck on the
eighth-ranked maybe he's going to
activate it though if I if I capture
this Rick and this Queen may look Oh
they're placed on the center file but
they're actually just looking at this
pond which is achieving nothing and this
rook and this bishop I would say are
well placed so black has maybe two three
well-placed pieces where as nearly all
of my pieces are ready to open the
position ready to attack things ready to
get into the game so of course I take
and open up the position because I'm
ready for it
he plays Bishop takes activating his
bishop and I play Bishop d3 so my least
active piece is now trading off for
blacks may be most active piece he
doesn't want to do this so he just plays
Bishop to g4 but this still leaves my
queen and Bishop you know on a battery
aimed at the King and you know tactics
are going to be coming soon
right already I can be looking for ways
to try to win material somehow to try to
break through maybe on the Kings side
maybe I have some sort of sacrifices to
think about maybe I can you know bring
this Bishop into c3 trade off another
one of blacks good pieces maybe I can
try to get my rooks in try to double up
on this weak pawn right so we see piece
activity and we see loose pieces and a
weak King so that's what means I can be
looking for tactics here I start off
with just Knight g5 we see Bishop d4 so
black is attacking my only kind of loose
or weak point in f2 I simply defend it
he plays Queen f6 I go ahead and take on
d4 opening up my rook again trading off
one of you know blacks most active
pieces C takes d4 this Knight is a text
I decided to move it to be six so this
is a fork which now forces black to
trade off kind of his last active piece
that isn't you know just on the F file
I'd take with the rook he plays Queen g5
and finally you know something something
has slipped in blacks position well yeah
it activates it also is activating my
rook it gains time against the Queen and
it allows me to you know maybe double up
maybe I have other ideas but Queen g5
was kind of the the final straw
something has gone wrong for black and
now I can play a tactic so what do you
think
yes AK the bishop right so we see a
loose piece here a weak King which you
can kind of count as a loose piece this
Knight is also undefended and you could
say loose but it doesn't contribute
specifically to this tactic but it's
another thing to look for
so of course white can simply capture
this pawn on g6 of course what would
happen if black were to recapture yeah
takes we have rook takes that's not what
happened in the game but this is the
point of the tactic right we do this and
then I can actually just come over and
checkmate him right away and there's
really nothing black can do so he chose
not to take and said he tried to kind of
defend in a tricky way with your up to
d6
so he's activating his pieces trying to
you know you know have some active
defenders just out of curiosity what
would happen if I did nothing here you
guys see mm-hmm obviously I would do
something but if nothing were to happen
has black made a threat yeah something
better than trading off the rook
actually this is using some of those
tactical motifs I talked about last week
if you remember yes you can take the
bishop because this is actually an x-ray
attack so if the Queen were to take or
if the rook were to take the rip to take
and if the Queen takes again the rook
comes in in the end so you know blacks
setting up you know maybe it may be an
x-ray on on the bishop of course though
this opponent h7 is simply hanging so I
captured it the King went over I just
brought in my last piece into the attack
Queen h5 was played I moved my bishop
because it was attacked
Queen g5 I played Queen d3 hear the
engine says well they're a thousand
better ways to play but Queen d3 is
enough for me he takes and now one last
combination to finish out the game
now what's the whole line what's the
whole line yeah and that would be
finally checkmate
so blacks King is sadly too too weak not
enough defenders so I have check check
and here is actually where he resigned I
think this is how the game ended he I
know he resigns somewhere around here
because of King f6 or at xe6 would
simply be a checkmate so again how do
you think things went wrong for black
what was the big thing that launched all
of these you know tactics all of the
pieces coming in yeah so f5 was was
really the big problem in the position
he played f5 and he should have realized
hey my pieces aren't as active as my
opponent's I'm not really ready to do
this yet and he should have come up with
something else maybe something as simple
as like e6000 steno keeping his King a
bit safer and you know ready to open
this up to bring his Bishop out still
but keeping things more under control
yeah thanks for sharing your game Perry
it was instructive stuff good luck yeah
so yeah something like east 6 less you
know kind of crazy you know keeping it a
bit more calm not opening the position
until you're really sure you're ready to
so yeah so tactics at the beginner level
again kind of just look like you know
missing things not realizing my pieces
are loose and attacks tactics at a
slightly loved higher level are you know
not paying so much attention to what
your opponent's doing you know focusing
on your own tactics you want to realize
hey I am weaknesses - I have loose
pieces - things gonna happen to me and
then finally at my level or the 1,800
level opening things up letting your
opponent have active pieces and then
tactics flow from there so now I wanted
to go all the way back to the 1800s and
see what things looked like
you know back then tactics wise how they
handled things so we see efore a
five-night of 390 654 Bishop c5 B 4 so
this opening doesn't get played very
often anymore but this was a this was
upon sacrifice that got played quite
often in the eighteen hundreds I believe
so it draws the bishop away allows white
to play this c3 move which is preparing
to breakthrough in the center with tempo
the black Bishop moves we see castles d6
d4 Bishop g4 Bishop b5 takes takes
excuse me so already we see you know
there's a pin here there's a pin here
maybe white is threatening to play d5
and when the knight
so black is gonna have to do something
about that we see Bishop d7 in response
Bishop to b2 white continues to just
develop it's kind of eyeing this loose
piece on g7 may be threatening to play
d5 and do something about it
so black actually just moves this night
away this is the first kind of mistake
because he's spending too much time
shuffling his pieces around and not
enough time developing and getting
castle but this does stop the tactic
with d5 and Bishop takes g7 so this
Bishop is attacks so white simply
captures green takes d7 983
so white is aiming to develop with tempo
they're both just fighting to have the
more active pieces here that's that's
all that's happening because once you
have the active pieces then the tactics
start to flow we see nine h6 this is a
very odd move and I don't know how to
justify it for black but he wanted to
develop his knight that way doesn't make
a lot of sense to me maybe it did to him
of course I would have preferred just
the simple Knight f6 this e5 move isn't
really something to worry about you'll
simply take it
trade Queens and you can come up you can
come here you can come here you can come
here really anywhere I don't think it
matters a great deal
but yeah Knight age six instead I don't
really understand it maybe he's better
at chess than me maybe he's worse at
chess than me so it's unclear Knight see
for attacking this loose piece getting
his
pieces active with tempo Bishop to b6 a
for once again we see a loose piece
white is actually threatening to trap it
so black has to spend more time dealing
with that now we see e5 so once white
has made sure he's got this piece on an
active square this piece controlling
important squares it's active he's
making this bishop active by opening the
position he's making this Queen active
by opening the position so he's claiming
all right the time has come my pieces
are ready for this your pieces aren't
that's what I'm gonna open it up and
that's what I'm gonna find tactics and
here black actually agreed black said
Wow okay you're right your pieces are
more active I'm not ready to open it up
give you all these squares so I'm gonna
play d5 and try to keep it closed
instead unfortunately for black this
actually gives him gives white this this
Knight nice check on d6 after King f8 we
see Bishop a3 again getting active
pieces so tactics can start to flow King
to g8 rook to b1 getting more pieces
active every piece on an active square
Knight hf5 and now just as the last
question before you guys and the Knights
need to get out of here what do you
think white played here you know he's
got an active piece here and active
piece here and act a piece here and
active piece here
he decided now is the time for me to
start my attack or start you know
looking for tactics it's actually two
options that kind of just win the game
he six
okay so those are two options east six
maybe black can just take it and I'm not
so sure about the point is this Knights
attacked now yeah I don't like you six
so much 95 that's an interesting idea
maybe this is somewhat good for white or
at least it would be it maybe Knight
takes d6 as possible you might play pawn
takes and Knight back to f5 or Bishop
takes and also Knight back to f5 and
maybe this is okay for black so there's
a simple way to do it and then there's
the way white did it in the game to try
to win here
so let's talk about the simple way first
how can Wyatt kind of break through what
are the loose looking pieces in blacks
position pieces and pawns just throw
them out there what looks loose this f7
pawn looks a little loose yeah
this Knight is pretty well defended it's
the furthest advance piece but it is
well defended I would say this Bishop
looks a little loose it can be attacked
quite easily and this pawn is attacked
once and defended once so I'd say it's
also loose so these are the loose pieces
that I see in the position so is there
any way we can find a tactic here to
take advantage of them what was that
yeah exactly a 5 is the simplest I think
it's also the best actually if I have
simply making the bishop move and then
we're coming right in with this rook and
this is really far too much for a black
to be able to deal with something like
Queen d8 and it's almost hard to pick
between all the good moves here maybe
knight of seven now maybe 95 now maybe
anything maybe just takes in the knight
g5 all of these moves look completely
winning for white so that was the first
one it took advantage of this loose
piece in this loose piece the way white
didn't did it in the game took advantage
of the final loose piece so with that in
mind just have the heart to play it
that's right he just sacrificed right
here yep so the King took the night and
yep so again there's only five minutes
left if you want to go prepare for the
tournament I won't be offended at all
no not quite Knight check he took
advantage of the placement of these
pieces here yeah so pawn check so the
fork horses like to recapture obviously
what happens if the Queen takes
yeah then this would be a fork so the
King took instead boy white continued
there are a few different ways to win
including rocky one g4 wins he played 95
first maybe not the most accurate but it
gets the job done
believe queen c8 was played now we see
the smooth Rick to e1 again he's not
really in a huge rush he knows my pieces
are far
more active than my opponents and his
King is weak I'll simply bring more
pieces into the attack until something
something has got to give is basically
White's thinking here we see King to f6
simply Queen to h5 bringing yet another
piece into the attack looking for more
tactics
maybe Queen f7 is a humongous threat so
black plays g6 and now let's look for a
yet another tactic here what do you
think white tried this one's a bit more
subtle I think than the last one
so the first move that might come to
mind is Knight to g4 when after a king
to g7 you can take this Knight and maybe
you go here instead it does feel like
this should be winning somehow though
although your queen is hanging so you do
have to deal with that first and this
position I think is winning for white
but something more forcing is what yes
so Bishop e7 is actually the move that
was played and so the idea is if Knight
takes what do we think here yes simply
something like Knight to g4 maybe Queen
to h4 and it should all be winning I
think he played King takes instead but
of course what does this allow yeah this
double check on g6 the black king has to
move why it simply captures this rook
black tries to take this pawn and I'll
just kind of quickly go rook b3 again a
model example of bringing the last piece
into the attack Queen to d7 rook to f3
rook takes we see g4 York g8 and now
what is let's see
well first we serve Queen h6 r of g6 and
now what's the last tactic that we see
here this one ended the game yet not
Queen f8 with the pawn maybe just king
out 7 then okay everything's winning but
I'll just show you show you up what was
playing the game we see this rook takes
which is the sacrifice and then there's
actually this is not quite checkmate but
it's a skewer of the king and queen and
I don't know we can see mate coming up
coming up quite quickly I won't play any
further but uh yes so that's how it
happened in India in the 1800s there's a
little you know heavy-handed a little
just sacrifice sacrifice sacrifice but
once again it all comes down to peace
activity at these slightly higher levels
the person with the more active pieces
is going to be
finding the tactics so that's how to
recognize it you know at that sort of
level I'll say goodbye it to you you're
playing the Knights right no all right
well then uh we're all in here for the
long haul I have one more level to show
you perhaps the highest level of chess
let's see what tactics look like you
know between Fabiano Cara Juana and Sam
Shanklin yes so this was played actually
it was a very short game as a 10-minute
game was played on chess calm yesterday
actually this was in the protest League
which go Archbishop's because we're
doing all right we're doing all right so
we'll see how Fabi managed to take down
Sam here I'll play through the opening a
little bit more quickly it was an
exchange Carol they developed their
pieces this h3 move looks a little
strange
it's just aimed at making this bishop
look awkward that's all it's doing is
taking away its last square for
development Knight f3 Bishop f5 you know
allowing white to take if he wants white
decided no I'm not interested castles
castles Bishop f4 94-92 we see their
works come to the open file or the semi
open file black pushes White's Bishop a
bit backwards Queen to g7 white goes
ahead and trades off Black's active
piece and activates his bishop again and
then on activates the bishop I don't
really know what Fabi was doing here
we'll give him a pass because it was a
10 minute game but this all looks a
little bit strange to my eyes we see f4
so black is again trying to get active
pieces he's blocking White's Bishop out
so let's see how Fabi managed to
untangle we see Bishop d3 yet again
Bishop takes Knight Queen takes Bishop
e5 Queen h5 e 4 so this is something I
wanted to talk about this isn't
necessarily related to tactics it's more
about peace activity but can you find a
plan to get both of whites bishops into
the game because that's of the utmost
importance here first of all first off
what are we gonna do with this Bishop
let's decide that
yeah exactly right that's totally
natural just putting it on g4
the next order of business is actually
this bishop though how can we try to
break free with that bishop
we have to charge it boy at the launch a
yeah but how can we actually achieve
that
how can we chip away at the pawn chain
when we have so few pounds left yeah
each force is something to do it's
actually a pretty good idea but Bobby
chose a little bit of a different route
so what would be the main problem with
something like g3 what would black play
in response is something like g3 do you
think yeah he might just simply push and
then we're stuck behind our own pawn now
and we want to put this other Bishop on
g4 so it's tough to see how to break
through with g3 if you can't play g4y a
white hasn't moved as Bishop yet so
first order of business is fixing this
Bishop so he comes back to e to look e 7
and he actually does come to this g4
square the natural square and now after
Queen e8 we do see this g3 break so what
do you think Bobby has in mind because
Sam very quickly played f3 keeping the
Bishop stuck so how do we get this last
Bishop to be active how do we free it
from behind the pawn Shane yeah we want
to push this pawn which is what I
believed led Bobby to take on e8 and
play Bishop f5 he simply wants to play
g4 get this last Bishop into the game
and once this pieces are active that's
when the tactics start to flow so we see
you're up to d 8 g4 b5 fob he plays b4
trying to stop flex line already attack
a5 and now this was actually a black's
big mistake so why is a5 a mistake white
has a very specific move aimed at taking
advantage of his piece activity
should be six so let's think what
happened in my game against Neil yeah he
opened up the position his pieces
weren't quite ready and then he lost the
game so how can white open it up because
it looks like this bishop isn't quite
ready for the opening of the Queen side
and these rooks also aren't placed on
the a and B files so how can white open
it up get more pieces into the game and
then find tactics to eventually win you
can capture in a5 and play your p1 but
the thing is you haven't actually broken
through right black still has everything
covered maybe he can simply play riff to
be seven something like Nexus e4 and
then bring this bishop in and your
advantage might start to dwindle
yes so that's exactly right
hobbies simply play as a four and now
this is going to allow his rook to jump
into the action and you'll start saying
that blacks pieces aren't well placed so
that's the key is knowing when to open
it up when you have the better placed
pieces and that's where you'll find
tactics and higher-level games
so Sammy tried to play B takes a we see
now b5 forcing this night to an awkward
square 97 simply rook e 2 b1 wrote p7 b6
Knight to c6 and now white has actually
activated a piece that you don't often
see very active he's activated a pawn
and this allows him to finally break
through and win material how do you
think that happened
we'll wait hold on yes so Bishop c7 is
how it happened
this work is stuck where can this trick
actually go I'm not entirely sure rook
to e8 but now Bishop to d7 and
everything is hanging so I'm not sure if
Sam actually resigned here know you
played king f7 we took the rook and
Bobby played a played on for a few more
moves and here Sam decided to resign so
it was a very simple tactic in the end
it was simply b6 Bishop c7 and then the
circus just completely trapped if it
comes to some place like f8 we still
just play this Bishop d7 move I think
and yeah the end the end is near so any
questions about how the tactics came
about in this game and in my game or
even in the slightly lower level games
about the tactics there all right I just
want to do a quick review of what I want
what I talked about today then so you
want to recognize tactics in your games
tactics occur when you have active
pieces first of all when your opponent
has loose pieces or a weak King
basically so active pieces loose pieces
and a weakness like a weak King or a
weak square other than that I wanted to
thank you all for watching coming out to
the class this has been the road to 2000
episode 2 all about recognizing tactics
in your games hopefully you'll be a
little bit more aware when they show up
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]